So now that we know that the program
generates virtual addresses but
the processor needs physical addresses
to access the actual memory,
let's see how the processor does the
virtual to physical address translation.
So the program generates
a virtual address.
This is what the load, for example,
will compute as its address.
The processor divides this
address into the page offset part
which tells us where in the page we are.
The virtual page number
which tells us which page
in the process are we talking about.
If we have a 4 kilobyte page 12 bits
are telling us where in the page we are,
and the remaining bits are telling
us what the page number is.
So let's consider the address FC51908B,
which is a 32 bit address.
The least significant 12 bits are
telling us where in the 4 kilobyte page
we are, so that's the page offset.
The more significant bits are telling
us what the virtual page number is.
Now what happens is we take
the virtual page number and
use it as an index into the page table.
In this case, the index into
the page table will be FC159,
so we find the entry with that index.
What that entry tells us is what
the frame number is that corresponds
to this virtual page number,
that is where did we put that page
in the actual physical memory.
Let's say that the frame
number in this entry is 00152.
We take this physical frame number and
put it together with the page
offset into a physical address.
And that is what we use to actually
access the physical memory.
In this example,
the physical address is composed of
the frame number and the page offset.
So this is a 32 bit physical address
that we will use to access the memory.
Note that the page offset is
present in both the virtual and
the physical address.
So from the virtual address, the least
significant bits that corresponds to
the page offset do not change when we
translate into the physical address.
But the virtual page number
does change because it gets
translated into the frame number.